welcome back so i am incredibly excited today
to tell you about partial differential equations
and so in this video what i'm going to do
is essentially motivate what are partial
differential equations why do we need to
solve them and i'm going to give you a
lot of examples of types of pdes that come up
throughout physics and engineering and science
okay so this is absolutely one of my favorite
topics um and i gotta say i am just so
grateful to have the opportunity to teach
this to you it's something that has you know
partial differential equations have changed my
life you know it allows you to solve problems
that uh you can't solve without them and so i
really really hope that this is kind of opens
a door to you like it did for me okay calculus is
kind of the same way it's one of those things that
once you see the world through that lens you can't
unsee it okay so a partial differential equation
there's a definition here it's essentially a set
of equations in terms of a multivariate function
and its partial derivatives and
so the multivariate function
um the multivariate function u
that i'm going to talk about u
is often a function of space and time okay so this
is my function um x is space and t is time and
this might be a this might be a scalar function
this might be the temperature distribution
on this piece of glass here so x would be a two
dimensional x and y vector so in general this
could be a vector u could be a vector and t could
be time or you could be a scalar like this could
be the temperature distribution like i said this
could be the fluid flow vector field of the error
in this room in which case you would have three
components the x velocity u the y velocity v
and the z velocity w and x would be a
three-dimensional space vector x y and z
so this is a very flexible function it's
a function of space and time typically
and the partial differential equation
is going to relate this function
and its partial derivatives so a good
example would be the wave equation so
i could say the second partial derivative of u
with respect to time is equal to some constant
uh some some positive constant times the second
partial derivative of u with respect to x
so in this case u is a scalar function this is
just a scalar function and x is a scalar you
know position along the x-axis and this would be
the equation for a wave uh you know kind of a wave
u of x and t propagating at some constant
velocity c okay and i'm going to you know we can
derive this we can analyze this this is just one
example of what a partial differential equation
looks like so again it is a relationship between
some function u and its partial derivatives here
i have a partial derivative and t and a partial
derivative and x now that's different than an
ordinary differential equation so um you know if i
looked at my ode this is just a sidebar if i look
at an ordinary differential equation it is usually
a single derivative of a function you know x of t
equals some uh you know function of x like
lambda x of t and in this case there is only one
variable that's being varied time so i have a an
independent variable time a dependent variable x
and i'm just taking derivatives only with respect
to that independent variable time whereas for
partial differential equations it has multivariate
dependencies it's a function of multiple variables
x and time in this case or maybe even multiple
spatial dimensions and so i have to think about
partial derivatives with respect to each of
those those independent variables okay good
uh so that is just kind of an example or a
definition of what a pde is and this is an example
what i want to do is i want to start building
up some of the most useful pdes that we use
like all the time in physics and engineering and
science and then we're going to start thinking
about what are some of those properties of those
pdes that are particularly useful so maybe one
of the things i'll start with is i'll just kind
of describe some of the canonical canonical pdes
and all of these canonical pdes that i'm
going to describe have some common properties
so they are going to be linear and i'm going to
define what i mean in a minute so they're linear
they are second order
and they are what is known as homogeneous
or homogeneous depending on homogeneous
okay so i'm going to define what each of these
means so linear just means that um the partial
differential equation can be written in terms of
linear operators where there's no nonlinear terms
like u squareds or u times u sub x and things
like that let me make a quick quick quick sidebar
that oftentimes we use subscripts like u sub t
to denote partial u partial t and things like u
sub x or u sub x x would equal the second partial
derivative of u with respect to x squared okay so
often times partial derivatives are denoted by
subscripts and i'm going to do the same thing
here so linear basically means that there are
no nonlinear terms there's no things like no
no products or cross products no products
between my various u u sub x u sub x x terms
so i don't have any u squareds or u times u x's
or u x times u x x's those would be non-linear
and i'm going to talk actually about linear more
later so just to remember that second order means
that there's no more than a second no derivatives
higher than second order no derivatives higher
than second order okay so you know i could
technically have a fourth derivative and x a
fourth order diffusion term there are physical
systems that have fourth order diffusion
uh but at least in these canonical pdes i'm going
to write down here we're only going to think about
second order pdes and uh homogeneous means that
there is no time forcing or spatial forcing so
the the governing rules of the system are the same
throughout time and they're the same throughout
space now for example in this wave equation this
is essentially the equation for a guitar string
okay and you could imagine building a guitar
string where the first half of it is nylon
and the second half of it is steel and in that
case that will be a non-homogeneous differential
equation because the the rules of the equation
will change on those different halves of the
guitar string because the material properties
will mean that the c is different in one part
of space than in another part of space so
what homogeneous means is that there is no
um time dependent forcing or spatial
dependent forcing no time dependent forcing
or space dependent forcing
and you know now that i'm thinking about
it that example i gave you is actually not
a good example of an inhomogeneous equation
so i can have an equation where the constants
themselves are functions of space um you know that
that's okay but i guess uh here what i mean is if
i actually actively force my system in time or in
space if i have some plus forcing function that's
a forcing of time and space and i'll give you lots
of equations examples of this for example in the
heat equation if i have a blow torch and i'm you
know actively heating up a metal plate that would
be an inhomogeneous term in that equation so we'll
we'll talk through all of this in a minute but
these are the three kind of basic properties for
these canonical pdes i'm going to write down now
and so i want to write down three basic
partial differential equations we have
we have the wave equation
which i've actually already
written down before we have
the heat equation this is one of the most
important equations in all of physics the heat
equation and we've already seen before when
we looked at potential flow we have laplace's
equation laplace's equation and laplace's equation
and heat equation are very very closely related
so here what i'm going to do is i'm actually going
to write these down and then we're going to talk
about what their properties are we're going
to confirm that they're linear second order
homogeneous equations so the first thing i'm
going to do is i'm going to write it down in
kind of a specific form for two independent
variables so the wave equation is u sub t
t equals a positive constant c squared u sub
x x that's actually exactly what i wrote down
here just using subscript notation and this is
for a one dimensional wave equation i have two
independent variables i have time and one spatial
coordinate x okay so this is a 2d version the heat
equation is another super important equation so
this one again for for a simple case is u sub t a
single time derivative a single time derivative of
u equals another positive constant we're going to
call this alpha squared times u sub x x now these
look extremely close to each other all that not
i pluck it you know i available these these
standing waves or if i take a a rope and i
whip the rope it will send this traveling wave
traveling along that rope and the shape will
kind of remain constant whereas for the heat
equation if i have some temperature distribution
in a one-dimensional piece of metal immediately
it's going to start to diffuse and average out
until it all becomes a constant temperature
which is very very very different behavior
just because of the single additional
partial derivative in this wave equation
okay and the the third canonical pde that we
always study uh in physics is laplace's equation
which is just the heat equation if i set u t equal
to zero it's the steady state heat distribution
uh like let's say i have a metal plate and i
heat one side you know in a hot bath and one
side in a cold bath and i insulate the other two
sides there will be a steady state temperature
distribution that is given by laplace's equation
so again i'm going to write this in two dimensions
as u sub x x plus u sub y y equals zero
now notice i'm actually writing this in two
dimensions this has two so so there's no time in
laplace's equation because it's for steady state
heat distribution and so this would be
how the the steady state heat distribution
has to satisfy this for a two-dimensional uh
heated object for example with boundary conditions
and again we already saw that you know we
already saw this from the potential flow
equations also solutions of laplace's equation
are potentials that we can use for potential flows
good so these are three canonical pd's i also
want to show you what this looks like in vector
calculus notation for arbitrary dimensions because
i think you know we've been essentially building
up partial differential equations like laplace's
equation using vector calculus div grad and curl
and so i want to show you what this looks like
for those cases as well okay good um so the wave
equation in nd is going to look like u uh u sub
t t equals again some positive constant now times
the laplacian of u okay and uh this is going to be
so if u is a function of x y and z this is now you
know second partial of u with respect to x squared
plus second partial of u with respect to y squared
plus second partial of u with respect to z squared
and you could in fact write down an n dimensional
a 10 dimensional laplacian operator if you like
it's easy same thing for the heat equation it's
just u sub t equals a positive constant alpha
squared again times the laplacian operator of u
and laplace's equation aptly named is just
the laplacian operator of u del squared u
set equal to zero and so these are kind of
the n dimensional this this would give you
the steady state heat distribution not just in a
two-dimensional plate but in a three-dimensional
object then you take the three-dimensional
laplacian or an n-dimensional object sometimes
for example in machine learning you might
add some kind of artificial diffusion on an
n-dimensional vector and you would need to be
looking at an n-dimensional laplace's equation
now there are more complicated pdes that
we use in our daily lives like the navy
or stokes equations are non-linear equations
okay so they are they don't satisfy this kind
of nice property that the solutions uh satisfy
superposition there's other equations that are
you know not second order like i
mentioned that if you had u quadruple
x there are systems that have that kind of
fourth order diffusion i can have systems
that are inhomogeneous i'm forcing them in space
or in time okay actively forcing those systems
and so we can essentially relax all of these but
These are the canonical building block partial differential equations
that we use to buildintuition to understand solution techniques and
so we'll actually spend a lot of time thinking
about how do you solve Laplace's equation
in fact we can derive separation of variables
one of the most powerful techniques to solve PDEs
we can demonstrate it on Laplace's equation
and then use it to solve the heat equation
you can use the Fourier transform techniques to
solve the wave equation and so these all become
very very useful as building blocks to
understand how partial differential equations work
good... are there other things I want to tell you?
I'm sure there are... in fact I think I'm going
to tell you lots more in other videos maybe one
of the things I'll mention is what does it mean
to be a linear PDE. So we've talked a lot about
this for ordinary differential equations. We know
that we like linear ordinary differential
equations specifically because it means that
linear superposition holds. If I have two solutions
of a linear differential equation, and I add up
that solution, it is still a solution. And that
also is what linear means for PDEs. So let
me just write this out... so linear is just a way
of saying that superposition holds
and so what that means... let's take the wave
equation, for example, if I have two solutions of
the wave equation I have two waves that are
traveling at some constant speed, I've got two
solutions u1 and u2 and I add that solution
up... I superimpose that solution, it will also
be the solution of the wave equation, because
this is a linear partial differential equation.
And in fact, like I mentioned, all three of these
equations are linear. That is super super useful.
So Laplace's equation tells me what the gravitational potential or the
electric potential is going to be in a medium
away from charge densities or point masses.
And again because linear superposition holds I
can have 10 charges and just add up the fields
from all of those charges to figure out what the
field is going to be at some distant location x
Linear superposition is one of the most
powerful tools we have in all of mathematics
to handle differential equations. I'm going to
say it again: When we say superposition holds,
this means if u1 and u2 are solutions to the PDE,
then in fact any constant alpha*u1 + beta*u2
is also a solution. And so that allows us to
essentially cook up basis solutions or "eigen"
solutions and then take linear combinations of
those for more complicated problems, for more
complicated boundary conditions, geometries,
etc., etc. And, in fact, that's how Fourier
analysis was invented... Fourier himself invented
this Fourier transform specifically to provide a
basis of eigen solutions for the heat equation.
So the heat equation, you can essentially
transform this into some diagonalized system
using these sines and cosines... this Fourier
transform that Fourier invented, and it
simplifies the heat equation and it provides
a family of unique orthogonal basis solutions,
so that any combination of them also satisfies
the heat equation. Really, really powerful
stuff. So we'll talk about all of this more, but I
really, really just love this idea that linearity
allows you to add up independent solutions of
these equations and there's still a solution.
And linearity also relates to the operators
themselves. So remember we're talking about
this Laplacian operator, del squared is equal to
the divergence of the gradient of whatever
function... so if I have the laplacian of "f"
it is equal to the divergence of the gradient
of "f" for some scalar value to "f" and
essentially these the gradient and the divergence
operator and therefore the laplacian operator
are linear operators the partial derivative
of a function u is a linear operator on u
and so that's something i really want to to
convey to you this is a kind of an abstract
concept but very important is that i'm just going
to give you some examples of linear operators so
a linear operator on u one example would
be if i just multiply it by a constant if
i take u times 5u that's a linear operator and
you can verify this because you can plug in u1
plus u2 and that's still equal to 5u1 plus 5u2
it's the linear operator of u1 plus the linear
operator of u2 so it's linear another linear
operator and this is really important and i want
you to verify this this is extremely important
is the partial derivative of u with respect to x
in fact the partial derivative of u with respect
to any of its uh the variables it depends on
partial u partial t partial u partial x
second derivative of u with respect to x
the laplacian of u the gradient the
divergence you know all of these
are linear operators and so i want you to actually
verify that uh this l of you know alpha u1
plus beta u2 right so if if u1 and u2
are solutions then i want you to plug
in this and confirm that this is alpha times
the operator of u1 plus beta times the operator
okay this thing is kind of a pain to
erase uh plus beta times the operator
of u2 and i'm just going to say this again so what
linearity means is that if u1 and u2 are solutions
to the pde then alpha u1 plus beta u2 is also a
solution and what that means for a linear operator
we build up this pde using these linear operators
this is a linear operator on u this is a linear
operator on you multiplying by c squared is a
linear operator on u this is all kind of l of u
equals zero a linear operator of u equals another
linear operator of u and so to confirm that an
operator like a partial derivative is in fact
linear we verify that if we take two functions
u1 and u2 and we add them up in some combination
a plus b then we hit that with the operator
you can essentially you know pop the operator
out you can pop these constants out and you can
split the sum so that it is equal to that
constant a times the linear operator of u1
plus that constant beta times the linear operator
of u2 and i'm gonna have you like get a piece of
paper actually verify this is true for partial u
partial x verify it's true for second derivative
of u with respect to x or for the laplacian
of u with respect to a multivariate function
of let's say x and y really really really
important okay and these are all linear pdes
maybe the last thing i want to show you before
you know we'll talk more about pdes a lot in the
next few lectures so i don't want to overload you
here but maybe what i will do for the last thing
is just give you an example of a non-linear
so this is not going to be a canonical pde
it's a non-linear pde and this non-linear pde is
going to be berger's equation so burgers burgers
equation it sounds delicious i'm quite
hungry so this is kind of a non-linear
burgers equation and i'm just going to write out
what this pde is and then we'll talk about why
it's non-linear okay so the partial differential
equation for burgers equation in one component
is the time derivative u sub t plus u u x equals
some viscosity uh u x x so again this is for the
one-dimensional burgers equation this u is just
a function of time and a single spatial variable
x and it also is going to be describing how waves
propagate uh in space and time but because we have
this non-linear term here this is a product
this is a product of u and u x this is not
linear you can try to do this for u u x and this
is not true so that's another thing i'd really
like you to verify that this is non-linear
and it's called a nonlinear uh convection
okay that's a really important term here and
we'll talk about burger's equation and the physics
more later but i also want
to point out in vector form
you can write this as a vector u sub t this is for
a higher dimensional burgers equation plus u dot
grad of u plus my sorry equals i i have
to erase twice in one video okay good
this equals my laplacian operator my new times
laplacian of u and i'm going to say
that this is for a vector valued u
so now u could be the velocity in the x
and the y component so this u could be
u equals you know u in the x direction and v in
the y direction and it's a function of x and y and
t so now i have to use these partial these kind
of gradient and laplacian operators to account
for those those partial derivatives okay good so
let's just take a step back and do a quick summary
uh to wrap up so partial differential equations
like ordinary differential equations like calculus
is one of the most powerful tools we have to
describe systems that change in space and time
the world around us changes in space and time
so your brain has you know it's changing as a
function of x and t constantly the atmosphere
the climate is changing as a function of space
and time the ocean is moving and flowing
as a space function of space and time
and this partial differential equation framework
allows us to relate that function we care about
and how it changes in space and time through these
relationships of partial derivatives generally
speaking we want to solve for this unknown
function u we want to solve this equation for
u that's usually the goal and that is typically
easier to do for these linear pdes because if
we can solve for kind of a basis of solutions
then linear combinations of those solutions also
are solutions uh but there's a lot of interesting
equations like this burgers equation is basically
uh kind of a 1d analog of the navy or stokes
equations and so you know for really nonlinear
fluid flows it you're not going to have that
linear superposition and we're going to have
to have other other solution techniques okay a
lot more on this coming soon stay tuned thank you